é
de la reine viennent à peine
de se terminer, rapidemetrtrtrte
est rattrapé par la réalité.
(vrombissement des moteurs)
Confronté à un vote de
confiance,ututututututututututue
ses députés de ne pas
l'abandonner. Résultat :
le premier ministre conser
(applaudissement
Mais derrière cette victoire
apparente, un fort
députés conservateurs ont exigé
son déparÀ l'origine,
des frustrations des fêtesrérére
officielle, Downing Street,
confinement. Présent à certainsn
a même reçu une amende
de la part de la police.uéuéuéu)
Signe de l'insatisfaction
ministre a même été hué
en se rend u u u une cérémonie
religieuse organisée dans le
cadre du jubilé de la Reine.
"C'était un moment
déterminant", dit cette
Cet autre reproche au premier
Des critiques qu'ont entendues
des élus conservateurs à travers
le pays. C C C C Ce député pens,
que Boris Johnson aurait dû
démissionner dès le moisemememer
ministre a aussi de nombreux
défenseurs.
Comme la ministre de la Culture,
qui vanttitititition du Brexit
et de la campagne
de vaccination. Le premier
son parti passe à autre chose
ete e e e e s'entre-déchirer.
Mais selon l'opposition
officielle, le mal est déjà
fait; les conservateurs
sont divisés
S'il a conservé son poste,
Boris Johnson ressort ememememer
l'électorat de lui faire
de nouveau confiance, il devra
commencer par convaincre
les membres de son
Raphaël, Boris Johnson a donc
son parti est loin d'être uni.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui l'a
maintenant?
RAPHAËL BOUVIER-AUCLAInsnsnsnsnn
ne pourra pas faire l'objet d'ue
venant de ses propres rangs pour
au moins un an. C'glglglglglglgi
conservateur, mais ça ne veut
pas dire que la pression
ne va pas cesser de s'accentuer
urururururururururururururururua
une épreuve électorale. Il y a
des élections parta a a a a a as
dans deux circonscriptions
en Angleterre. Deux sièges
conservateurs sont en jeu et sit
cas, pour l'une de ces deux
circonscriptions, le Parti
conservateur est en danger,
pression sur le premier ministre
si son parti perd ces él
Et puis, on en revient aussi,
les fêtes à Downing Street.
J'ai p j j j j j j j jours
au cours de la dernière semaine
pendant le jubilé de la Reine,
et même pendant ces activités,
lorsqu'on parlait à des
c'est un sujet qui revenait.
Donc, cececececececece que
ce vote de confiance est chose
du passé, les électeurs
cesseront de parler de cet
enjeu, qui a nui à l'image de
certain. Le premier ministre
veut tourner la page, donc,
mais ce n'est pas clair
si facilement.
- Oui, ce n'est peut être pas